i have a show where i interview kind of
top achievers and you know athletes
entertainers business people and when i
started the show i thought it's gonna be
fascinating to find out what they all
have in common is it hard work
brilliance charisma
and frankly it's on it's a skosh of
unhappiness because achievers even
people like yourself and this is people
that are that are out there like that
who should consider this we have this
thing where we're really never living up
to what we think we're capable of and
that's a good thing because it pulls us
to get better but it can also be a
formula for misery if you never just
decide you know a lot of achievers think
well if i enjoy this moment right now
i'm going to lose my drive i'm going to
lose my ambition so they cheat
themselves for all of the joy
all of the juice that comes from winning
and i found if you give yourself that
dopamine hit when you achieve something
you allow yourself to enjoy it your
brain wants to do it again and again and
again but if you rob yourself of it
that's when burnout starts to happen
because you're not giving yourself any
of the rewards for your hard work